the guinness book of world records will
let you jump a rocket car
across the grand canyon you can juggle
flaming chainsaws
you know there's all the stuff you can
do you cannot go for
a unbroken sleep deprivation challenge
because the last three people that have
tried it they get between nine and 11
days they tap out they go to bed
and they die and they have no idea why
they die
rob wolf welcome to the show hey huge
honor to be here thank you
thanks for tolerating the uh the many
reschedules that we had with my moving
and everything
absolutely fine so you've just made the
move to montana how come
uh a variety of reasons uh
primary to it i have eight and
six-year-old daughters
and they grew up in this northern nevada
area
and four seasons it snows
um they played in the snow they you know
we had nice summers and stuff also and
then we moved to texas which was
cool in a lot of regards but it snows
there about once every 35 years
and they wanted to murder me for doing
that to them
so um the move to montana brought us
closer to family it also
uh definitely we just i didn't realize
it like we grew up in the
the mountainous area and as cool as the
hill country of texas is
just very very different and then
there's also a straight blast gym
here in uh kalispell montana that's just
phenomenal and the whole family does
brazilian jiu-jitsu and it's a
an amazing community here there's
actually three gyms within the greater
flathead valley area so within
30-minute drive of my house i have three
different gyms that i could go do
jiu-jitsu with so
uh multiple factors but those are the
biggies yeah
it's so interesting as someone from the
uk to hear you essentially say
the weather wasn't bad enough yeah
um we uh you know it's funny because the
the bad weather is kind of relative like
uh and we lived in a part of texas that
was
uh that is understood to be very mild
weather-wise comparatively um it's not
the heat and humidity of say like a
houston or a dallas or like a corpus
christi or what have you but um
on like a christmas day uh you know
celsius it would be
32 35 degrees celsius or something like
that
you know and and uh we're sitting
outside you know barbecuing
and and it was interesting like i
i think most places if it's if it's like
cloudy outside you have the sense that
it's going to be cool like you might
need a sweater and in
texas if it's cloudy outside um
it means the humidity has come and it's
actually
hotter than what it is normally you know
it's like
putting a blanket around like a baked
potato or something and and
again where we were it's not that bad
but um the kids would go outside they
would ride their bikes and they'd run
outside
and then they'd come back in and they
were just like bedraggled and
and hot so like bad weather was was
relative and kind of what we've noticed
is cold weather you can always put some
clothes on and kind of deal with that a
variety of ways but if it's hot
and in particular humid you just
there's not a lot of escape like you
just kind of sit inside and hope that
the air conditioning doesn't break or
something like that and it's definitely
cool in some ways like the kids spent
the whole year swimming like we
the kids were swimming in uh november
and december in the backyard pool
you know it was cold but they they were
still able to do it we definitely don't
do that
in in montana so yeah yeah
yeah it's an interesting one man it's
the uk kind of doesn't really have
weather i mean we just have an absence
of anything
on the extremes it kind of gets a bit
cold and a bit gray
in winter and then it kind of gets a bit
less cold and a little bit less gray in
summer and then it vacillates back down
again
but um yeah man some of the some of the
the buddies that i've got that
spend time in montana or go out there
hunting or doing whatever
it looks absolutely spectacular so it
does not surprise me that you've decided
to go there
i want you to go through um ancestral
health today which is one of the terms
that kind of
swims in the circle that that your work
sits in the epicentre of
for people that aren't familiar with it
how do you characterize the foundations
and the fundamentals of ancestral health
uh it's really taking a perspective
that uh if we buy into this notion of
evolution via natural selection
that most organisms end up being fairly
well suited for the environment that
they're in
and that changes in the environment
could be either beneficial
neutral or negative for the organism and
when we look at
modern human existence um
nobody's really quite sure what the year
was or what the date was but somewhere
around like 2004
2005 humanity made this really
fascinating shift where more people
started dying from chronic degenerative
disease than from
infectious disease and starvation and
this is the first time in our
our history you know 2.5 bill you know
million years of of human pre-human
history
it's always been infection and scarcity
that were the the main killers and now
it's is diseases of abundance and so
this is kind of a
primary example of where an evolutionary
or
ancestral health perspective could maybe
be really valuable
in how do we approach this stuff like
simply telling people
eat less move more we've had 60 years of
that and it just fails because it
actually goes
exactly contrary to the evolutionary
wiring that every organism has which is
eat more
move less because this this is the way
you survive in a
in a world absent you know significant
technology and the
benefits of of being able to to share
information
you know via written and spoken language
and all that stuff so
it's a it's an idea that we don't like
go back to trying to
reenact the way that we lived or live
under a bush or anything like that but
just where
we see problems particularly with
regards to human health like
maybe we could we could look back a
couple of generations or a couple
hundred years even we don't even have to
go like
you know caveman era to get some really
interesting insight
the development of the electric light
bulb is one of the most amazing things
that ever
has has you know been um gifted to
humanity but it's got a cost to it too
and i think that that's one of the the
big things that
isn't properly discussed within medicine
at large in like this this age of covet
is a pretty good example of this
like uh folks present things as if there
is only
a benefit or a negative and never that
there's
usually a risk profile associated with
that and that
maybe we don't know exactly what the
story is but if we have a discussion
around this you know maybe we can ferret
some stuff
out it's pretty clear now that shift
work
is as injurious to health as a
you know like a pack a day smoking habit
it's rec you know
recognized by the world health
organization shift work as being a known
carcinogen because of the
metabolic dysregulation that it imparts
on us
why is that because it's a really
remarkable departure from the way that
we've lived historically
and so what do we do about that i'm not
entirely sure but if we're not having a
conversation about it we're
certainly not going to find any answers
you know if we're just kind of
doing these very myopic you know views
about
sleep and circadian biology gut health
and what
whatnot so i i don't know if i properly
answered the question around what
ancestral health is but it's really just
it one thing it is not it is not an
answer
it is a question and hypothesis
generation engine it's a place that we
begin
asking questions to try to get to
answers and sometimes it can point
a likely direction of investigation but
i think that that's where
folks in the paleo diet or ancestral
health scene
ran afoul of the more established
scientific community by
saying well cavemen did x so our
response should be y and it's like no
cavemen may have done x what might those
implications be for today and what are
the studies
that we're going to do to try to figure
it out whether or not that
that's true or not true or some other
detail in there
are there broad buckets that you focus
on in the and the
ancestral health sort of paradigm yeah
and i i guess i kind of broadly drop
things into
food movement sleep and uh
community and you know within the
community i get kind of cheeky and i
i dump the gut microbiome in that
because like we're we're collaborating
together you know i'm
i'm more of a lumper than a splitter so
it you know but i
i think about like our we evolved in in
extended small family groups and whatnot
and there seems to be some real power to
to the the benefit of having adequate
community but those are kind of the
the broad buckets and again like i'm
really like i stick a lot of stuff under
those
those umbrellas for sure yeah it's funny
that you talk about shift work and the
effect on health
so my background for the last decade and
a half
i've run nightclubs so i'm a club
promoter a director of one of the
biggest events companies in the uk
so i've stood in the door of more than a
thousand club nights in between the age
of 18 and 33
i've lost a thousand different
nights and then the subsequent slow
reset back to something that
resembles normal and the maddest thing
about kovid was
for the first time in my entire adult
life
i had a stable sleep and wake pattern
first time
ever wow since i was a
legal child right right and what was the
impact on your life
with that i mean clearly it's hard to
fare it out because it's got all these
other
knock-on effects of like social
isolation and whatnot but
what what what did sleeping well do for
you
it made a profound difference i'd
already started to take the red pill
i suppose with regards to sleep um
matthew walker was a big
a big impact on that that joe rogan
podcast i would
i would guess that it's added thousands
of years of collective life onto
the entire human population people
realizing oh
god just the the the effect of
suboptimal sleep is catastrophic and it
was the same for me and i was like right
okay i need to prioritize this
but really if you're doing if you're
working
a typical week for me might have been do
a a tuesday night friday night saturday
night so i would have worked until about
3 30 4 a.m
on each of those and then tried to fit
training in and
such like around that but there is no
mitigation strategy
do you want to try and stay on that
schedule no way i don't want to stay up
until fourth at
four o'clock in the morning on the
nights when i don't need to obviously
but then you also still need to get
stuff done you got to be up you got to
go to the office you probably got a
meeting in the club
also the thing the insidious thing about
being a promoter is the most cognitively
demanding part of the night at the very
end when you count the cash and you
complete
the sheets and do the accounts that's
the thing that you do at the very end
just before you then about
precisely you're also really hungry
incredibly hungry at that time so if
you're trying to die i mean
essentially a calorie deficit whilst
working those shifts is borderline
impossible
and the only places that are open at
that time are takeaways and it's just
it is a catastrophe um
and then it comes to you know whatever
14 months ago
all clubs are shut down this we still
haven't been back into a nightclub in
normal process
since then um and
i found the main changes that i found
were
with my mood and with my calorie
consumption
so my mood was so much more stable
um i was able to actually know and a
third one would be consistency of habits
um what you're doing what you're doing
when you have shift work is you're
programming inconsistencies into your
life
which means that if you're trying to do
something hard
like build new myelin down somewhere i
want to wrap milo in around this
meditation habit or this
walking after i eat every meal for 15
minutes habit or what reading whatever
it might be
it just makes everything harder i always
wanted
worse food and more of it when i was
tired
and my mood i i found and all of these
as well will have contributed to each
other right if i was
eating better food i would be in a
better mood which would mean i would
have more discipline and resilience to
do the habits and it became this
and man i've made more progress over the
last 14 months than
in a significant period of time before
that and i thought i was working pretty
close to capacity beforehand
so yeah the foundation that's stable
sleep and i've got buddies that are
doctors nurses firefighters policemen
and um
i i really you know i feel for them
because that there is a cap being put on
what you can do outside of your life
um outside of work with your life
because it's just it's so suboptimal
yeah yeah it is and uh it's uh
it's something that societally we need
to really
figure out how do we take care of those
folks and to some degree how do we
protect them from themselves you know
it's it's ironic that uh
uh within medical circles in particular
fo
it and it's tough because folks will
work multiple shifts
and they you know to make more money
that's kind of how they plan for
retirement and stuff like that
but after that first eight hour shift or
ten hour shift they're garbage
like they are as cognitively impaired as
somebody who
has a blood alcohol level of like a
point one like they would be legally
drunk were this caused by ethanol but
it's caused by sleep
deprivation and we're paying them more
to remain in the hospital
or or whatever and again it it's tough
because folks will be like oh i'm fine
and for
super repetitious skills you can get
through it like you
you you know this is where surgeons can
be super sleep deprived but they've tied
those knots
a million times but if you're faced with
a novel situation and you need to make a
decision
that's where things can go horrifically
wrong and we have to kind of
wrap our heads around societally what do
we do about that
you know yeah did you see i think it's
matthew walker cites this study
about the significant proportion
of doctors or surgeons or nurses who
after working
an over over exaggeratedly long shift
then end up back in the same hospital
having had a crash on the way home
yes yeah yeah it's remarkable yeah
and then there's another one about when
daylight savings comes in
25 increase in is it stroke or heart
attack
or something it's all it's uh motor
vehicle accidents and i mean it varies
but
uh it's remarkably stressful just that
one hour shift
you know and then um i think about all
the travel
that i did where i would wake up and i'm
like i don't even know which
state country or continent i am on
currently like i would
take me a minute grab oh okay in germany
or i'm here or
whatever and that uh you know just a one
hour shift
we see it at a a uh i guess kind of a
systemic level and then you can
extrapolate that down you know
doing east coast west coast in the
united states
it's three times as worse you know and
and uh
yeah i i wonder how much
time i took off the end of my life by
just my travel schedule in the past you
know
yeah well i mean that's that's the same
if you're talking about smoking a pack
of cigarettes a day well that's it i
could have i could have just
not worked in nightlife and decided to
sit at home and blaze up for the entire
day
have you got any other statistics or
sort of crazy stories that you've come
across in your research to do with
suboptimal sleep or sleep deprivation
well it
i've stole most of my stuff from dr kirk
parsley he's a retired navy seal and
then he ran
the west coast um kind of medical
concerns for the seal teams for about
eight years
here's just an interesting side note
the guinness book of world records will
let you jump a rocket car
across the grand canyon you can juggle
flaming chainsaws
you know there's all the stuff you can
do you cannot go
for uh a unbroken sleep deprivation
challenge um because the last three
people that have tried it they get
between nine and 11 days
they tap out they go to bed and they die
and they have no idea why they die
but it's like it's virtually a a given
um there's some other interesting stuff
there have been studies where
a couple is um they get a group of
couples
one of the the husband or wife is sleep
deprived
one hour and then they they survey the
folks like
how loving and caring and affectionate
is is your significant other
if one spouse is sleep deprived both
report that the other one is a bigger
dick than what they normally are
and so it uh it just kind of spirals
down from there
um one hour of sleep deprivation
accumulated daily by the end of a week
leaves an individual
as cognitively impaired as if they were
like a blood
you know 0.1 blood alcohol content but
the
the really insidious thing about um
serial sleep deprivation is you
habituate to it and it becomes your new
normal
you you don't when you've been sleeping
well and then you have a super bad
night's sleep you get up the next day
and you're like man i really feel that
but if that goes
on you don't really feel quite as bad
so you aren't even as aware of how
you know your reaction time is off your
your uh
critical thinking skills and you alluded
to a bunch of the the problems
around the rest of you know like diet
and
lifestyle your decision making is poorer
you crave saltier sugarier foods you
know hyperpalatable foods
uh your willpower is gone like it it
just
it's like doing a willpower you know
excision
process like you literally have no no
willpower
um the tendency to be cranky and and
have uh
overly emotional responses are
dramatically increased
something like 85 percent uh in the
united states 85 percent
of excessive force cases within policing
occur within 24 hours of a significant
shift change
and i think about myself like if i have
a really bad night's sleep
and somebody cuts me off my kids are
kind of being
problem like my reasonable
response is very difficult to reach you
know it
and so you think about police work which
is challenging under the best of
circumstances and then they're subjected
not just to
the shift work itself but it's typically
a shift
change you know where they've gone from
day shift to night shift or vice versa
you know there's some significant delta
that occurs
that really messes with their ability to
to do that executive functioning in the
the
you know the um
more emotionally intelligent type type
responses so is this a case for
when you do a shift change like the the
cop is on
desk duty or light duty or they've got
somebody who hasn't been off of uh
shift change but this again like we've
got to pay for that stuff
but societally how much would we save by
taking care of these people and and
understanding the risk exposure we place
them in with the shift work
and the shift changes and do some
backstops to try to prevent that you
know in the united states the george
floyd thing is
just created so much much chaos and
drama and loss of life
loss of property and i don't know if
derek chovin
had just gone through a shift change but
exactly what i was saying you know it's
it's like
you know how much other stuff might we
mitigate
if we we use some of this to inform like
public policy
yeah it's um the interesting thing about
sleep
specifically is
the externalities and the costs
inevitably even for the individual
there's some hyperbolic discounting
right we think about how far we're going
out into the future before
the inevitable onset of inc rapid onset
of alzheimer's or perhaps some sort of
other
other cognitive decline but because
you can't see it right you can't see
something happening to a person for
instance if there was
a substance some sort of toxic substance
that a particular
portion of the workforce had to deal
with and what that substance
exposure to that substance caused to
occur were the same effects
as this deprivation of sleep we would be
up in arms
look you're destroying these people's
marriages you're forcing them to eat
this food that they need to eat because
they've been
exposed to this particular substance
they're
cranky and then we've got this problem
with the police because the police need
to deal with it as well
the the issue is that it is
so closed doors we don't see the effect
and we don't see
the actual occurrence and the the main
thing actually i think
that i realized when going back to when
i first saw that matthew walker podcast
on rogan
it's so front and center of all of our
lives it's so ubiquitous
that you can't see the wood for the
trees
yes you don't realize that it's a thing
you just it's
especially if you're a hard charger
right if you're a type a go-getter
sleep is just the thing that gets in the
way in between the two periods of waking
and working
right right yeah and i mean look at a
lot of the
you know the um the folks that we really
idolize you know surgeons navy seals
they're selected for their ability to to
deal with sleep deprivation you know and
and there are some outlier
characteristics like uh
seals uh generally um
walk around with a neuropeptide pyy
that's like 600 percent higher than the
rest of the
what's up population it it's a i'm not
it
nobody's entirely sure exactly what it
does but it seems to be
very key to stress inoculation
resiliency and
and whatnot is that highly heritable
i believe so yeah yeah i believe there
are some heritable uh characteristics
there and i'm only familiar with it
within these kind of
seal populations but is the difference
between somebody who makes it through
surgical residency
or not because they've got this you know
particular polymorphism or whatever
that's all well and good um but you can
break those people eventually they will
break
at some point like there's this isn't an
infinite well that they can go to but we
really do
hold them up you know in in high esteem
celebrities ability to motor through and
be tough and
and all that type of stuff and and there
are you know it's funny just when you
think about
it so i'm almost 50 i have an
eight-year-old and six-year-old daughter
is very grateful for when i did have
kids in my life just like kind of
unfucking my own
mental baggage and you know different
things like that more more financially
sound
but man when i was 20 i could deal with
sleep deprivation
dude you're speaking to me so i'm 33 i
don't have
i don't have kids i'm not engaged i'm
married or anything and this is in the
back of my mind i can't wait to be a dad
i'm so excited to be a dad i've spent
all of this time sorting my [ __ ]
right making me the sort of i would have
been a [ __ ] dad at 23
i would have been able to deal with the
sleep deprivation but i hadn't sorted
myself i still haven't sorted myself but
you know what i mean i'm better
and um but it does make me think
you're gonna be you're gonna be dealing
with open nappy changes
and all that sort of stuff when you're
in your 40s
and yeah i might have to message you and
try and get whatever the tips are
you the main tip is just grab what you
can
and and uh you know it uh
it's funny and i don't want to drive
this in into you know like uh being a
dad land but
um it was interesting when they were
kind of newborn up to about i don't know
maybe two years two and a half years
both of them slept pretty well like we'd
put them to bed
they go to bed about six 6 30 they'd
sleep 12 hours
so we still had kind of an evening we
could watch a little tv
hang out chit chat and everything and
now as they've gotten
older um they want to do stuff uh
they getting in the way asking for
activities and attention
yeah yeah i mean they went to jiu jitsu
yesterday they had jumped on the
trampoline all day
then went to jiu jitsu did a bunch of
matches because
kids got new belts and they iron man the
kids so everybody
you know it was all the stuff we got
home we fed them and then they went back
out on the trampoline
and get this it they turned the
sprinkler on the trampoline
and it was still chilly here but they're
out jumping in their swimsuits on the
trampoline in montana
in the spring you know and i'm just like
i don't know that i ever had that much
energy but i guess maybe i did it
maybe they've got that that pyy
i don't know man wait wait what is it
one in
the same number of people that get
struck by lightning twice in their
lifetime have that genetic modification
that allows them to go on whatever it is
four or five hours sleep you should get
them
you should get the kids tested man you
might have two two double lightning
strikers there
i think part of it is that i'm old and
they're young and well-fed
and that's really all there is this is
just biology it's like i'm ready to die
and they're just in the the budding part
of life you know so yeah
[Laughter]
yeah so okay so we've got we've scared
people straight about that what happens
when sleep's bad
what what would you say are your highest
three priorities for improving sleep
quality or what are some of the things
that you focus on
man um proper glycemic load is really
big
like some people do well on high carbs
some people do better on lower carb but
i do
find that um sleep disturbances
oftentimes relate back to so like some
people on very low carb
they can have sleep just problems and
they actually need to address some
electrolytes to usually get that that
fixed like sodium ends up being a piece
of that
um but i do notice that if folks are
eating an
overly refined diet uh too many carbs
for their constitution
it can kind of disturb their sleep that
that's definitely something that can
wake them up
um man i gotta say that
this is it this gets into personal stuff
and i don't know
i think it applies to everybody but um i
pulled
all social media off of my my phone like
like uh
six months ago um i will do some
via the desktop and even from there i
write stuff
now and then i send it to my assistant
my assistant posts it and i don't really
go on like instagram or twitter very
very rarely like i have somebody else do
that but um
my sleep improved dramatically just
decoupling from
social media i think the base level
stress of of just all the [ __ ] that's
going on
and it may be different for somebody if
they're just kind of like
my stuff was always like there's always
a battle i've gotta fight whether it's
like the
you know the the knuckleheads within the
ancestral health it's like well
30 grams of carbs is keto and 50 grams
of carbs is not keto and they're
bickering over that
and while that's happening i also have
folks saying that
um animal husbandry like cattle are
going are the
singularly largest contributors
greenhouse gases they're going to
destroy the world
and so i'm trying to tackle that thing
so like there were a lot of different
you know things that i was i was trying
to address and what i started doing was
just
um looking at what the concerns are
doing broadcast only whether it's a
written piece or like a podcast and then
that's it
and then i don't really interact after
that
and that was huge for me like the the
just the stress level dropped
and i discovered that doing that freed
up about three to five hours a week
of time that i was previously like
interacting with people which
some of it i really enjoyed like i
learned a lot
interacting with people on social media
like i can connect with somebody in
in the uk or you know anywhere in the
world at any time of the day it's
there's some really cool elements to it
but it i i think it's safe to say it got
pretty toxic
and so uh i think looking at glycemic
load i think looking at just kind of
tech in general like how much you're
doing
when you're doing it um here's an
interesting
is an interesting one for you that you
might not have seen i looked into some
papers
that studied the equivalent effect on
melatonin release and circadian rhythm
from e-readers versus
kindles and they actually said that even
the normal paper white so you don't need
the fancy oasis that's got a warmer
light on it
um basically the effect of the light is
negligible
on a night time which for those of us
that are part of the
uh kindle club bowing at the altar of
amazon
um right that's really good news because
it means you don't need to have a paper
book and
your big light on or even a reading
light on you can go
really dim and you know you can have it
as far away from your face as you want
and then you kind of
turn over and go to bed so that was that
was an interesting one that i discovered
a couple of months ago that
if you are wanting to read on a night
time the optimal solution it would
appear
is to go kindle turn the brightness down
and
get away yeah and i mean i i also do the
little extra bit i'll put on some blue
blocks
with it and i mean what's your blue
block is what are your blue blue
blockers of choice i've had matt marooka
from raw optics on here if you're
familiar with those guys though
i have a pair of those i i have a pair
of i suspect just about everybody's and
my kids steal them and they end up in
weird places like on their animals and
stuff like that and so
of course i'm just at the spot where um
any port in a storm you know it's it i
no no joke um i took
some play glasses that my kids have and
took a red
uh sharpie marker and put that on the
lens because it was a clear lens and i
used that for like three days because i
couldn't find
any of my other stuff and so uh i'm
i'm very non i'm kind of like the guy in
the bar
that it's like 3 a.m and i'm just kind
of looking around like who am i going
home with and so with
my blue blockers like i am very
undiscerning
that's so funny man that's so funny i
had so moving on the diet we've talked
about sleep one of the big ones
hopefully giving people some good good
bits of advice there
i had diana rogers on the show a few
months ago and i asked what most people
get wrong with the diet and she said
insufficient protein i'm gonna guess
that your answer would be the same
absolutely yeah and i mean i've i've
been around
the horn on this where uh uh
i mean just really looking at it
clinically like there's great
data from a research perspective that
really supports this position but
we we have a community called the
healthy rebellion where we do these uh
resets three or four times a year folks
are trying to lose weight or get get
improve their physical capacity a whole
host of things
and what's fascinating to me is folks in
there will say man i've been following
your work for 10 years 12 years it
really helped me
um but i've still had this problem like
losing the last 15 pounds or you know
whatever the
whatever the case may be and then when
we get in and really weigh and measure
their food for
a couple of days a week they're 25 to 50
percent
under eating protein and it shocks them
and and you know for us
we have never yet seen somebody have
body composition
issues that was over
eating protein they have always been
under eating protein now
every once while somebody will be
overeating in general but
it it's kind of like okay well shift the
rib eyes into something that's maybe a
little bit leaner or something
but even then i mean that's that's like
a fewer than one percent of people like
everybody's under eating protein and you
get that protein dialed in
and it's somewhere between like a gram
of protein per pound of lean body mass
up to
a gram of protein per pound of body
weight so there's a pretty good
pretty good spectrum there and then you
figure out
do you run better on fatter carbs or
maybe a little bit of a combo so you
figure out kind of your glycemic load
like i just seem to do better on
on kind of lower carb higher fat
not everybody does but once you get that
protein part buttoned up
then you figure out you know how much of
the other stuff do you need
and then you just go out and kick ass
and and rock the world and and uh
it is so easy if you can just get people
to eat that adequate protein and like
i just emphatic like it's got to be from
whole real food like shakes don't cut it
i wish they did
um it in a pinch for some people
okay but like even my my i don't do a
ton of work with athletes
but it's rare even with athletes that i
find that a shake
trumps real whole food that you gotta
chew and like the
the satiety and the the nutrient density
of it and whatnot but yeah that
that protein piece is is huge and diana
the clinical practice that she does she
just sees this again
and again again folks are just like
chronically under eating protein
like shockingly the problem is
especially if you want to go
one gram per pound of body weight
i'm around about 200 pounds there is no
chance in hell
that i am accidentally eating 200 grams
of protein per day no one in history has
acted unless you went to one of those
buffets and decided that you were not
going to look at any of the carbs and
just went through the meat
so give me some advice how
can people consume more protein get more
protein into their diet
especially if we're not permitting them
the the allowance is taken away with
bars of protein and with supplements of
protein
how do you advise someone hits that 200
gram or that 180 or that 160 per day
yeah i think a couple of different
angles on this one is definitely
looking at your seasoning like seasoning
sauces things like that like kind of
switching that up because it can get
very monotonous
just eating talk me through some of your
favorites chicken thigh
i i like so if we do kind of a matrix
where we've got like
garlic ginger black pepper
paprika and then we have three different
fats say like olive oil coconut oil
and beef tallow um you've got 15
different kind of flavor
options there you know so you could do
chicken
in garlic with beef tallow um
chicken and garlic with olive oil and
it's a very different flavor experience
so
this is a thing called the food matrix
that i developed a long time ago it was
pretty prominent in my second book wired
to eat
so just a little bit of variability
there can really help
uh you know getting some some different
flavor experiences there
something we've noticed too and this
takes a little bit of planning but if
folks cook say like some beef some
chicken
and some shrimp and they have a little
bit
of each or maybe the meal is mainly beef
with a little bit of chicken and shrimp
so one of the ways that we help
limit people from overeating is actually
limit limiting pallet options we have
fewer options there so from a caloric
control perspective that's a great
strategy but from getting a protein in
like you start
you're like like rib eye is great but by
the time you get past your sixth or
seventh ounce of ribeye you're kind of
like oh man this is getting to be a lot
but if you had a little bit of chicken
to break it up a little bit of salmon or
or shrimp or something to break it up so
it takes a little bit of planning but if
you can get
two or three proteins at a given meal
then that can certainly help and those
have been two of the the main strategies
that we've recommended within our
community and
people really do well with it and
sometimes it's just uh
you got a piece of steak and then you've
got a can of salmon and you put some
mayonnaise in the salmon and like
you do half of that and then save half
of it for the next deal and then
that rolls over to your next day and you
scramble the salmon into some eggs and
then that that flavor combination is
different than just salmon by itself or
eggs by itself so you start getting some
of these combos going
yeah that is because you're coming at
the
meals from a protein base whereas most
people
would maybe look at it from either a
carb base or a vegetable base
like if you were to say here's your meal
and
all the vegetables in it are spinach
you're like well so you're telling me
i've got like 150 grams or 200 grams of
spinach in this one meal and you want me
to just eat that
we'd say that was crazy but it's very
rare unless you get like the seafood
platter
or a surf and turf or something at a
restaurant it's very rare that you go
and you get i'll have the chicken with
beef please
right that's just not what happens and i
think that that's now been replicated
when we cook for ourselves the number of
times that i have two different meats
that i've made for myself in one meal is
almost zero so that's
i mean that's a really good suggestion
that i'm going to guess that if you were
to do
eggs on a morning then putting some ham
in with that or putting some tuna in
with that is another good way to do it
how are you cooking have you got any
advice about sort of expert
expedient ways to cook multiple
different meats or what are some of your
favorite ways to
to get the beef going if you've got
seafood going and chicken going at the
same time
yeah so having kids like that
complicates it's a little bit
um you know it's like one kid likes this
so i try to find things that pretty much
the
the kids do eat what we put in front of
them but at the same time
like just seeing your kid kind of
pushing the same piece of meat around
the plate and like trying to hide it
like
i i try to cater to them a bit so like
shrimp
is something that both girls eat really
well salmon is something that both girls
eat really well
the shrimp we can get frozen like we can
get wild caught frozen
and it's really easy to measure out how
much we want
and that one lends itself to cooking
like i could cook it in butter
i could cook it in olive oil i could
cook it in butter and garlic i could do
it olive oil and garlic i could do some
thai seasoning i could do some indian
seasoning
so again with that and so maybe
um i have some beef that's left over
like we have a traeger it's like a
pellet fired um
uh uh kind of kind of grill it's pretty
big and so i will cook
three racks of ribs uh uh eight to
twelve hamburgers
and then like a couple of steaks and
then we freeze some of that
and and we'll rotate that stuff through
so
um i it and really for me
i i'm able to kind of grind through
stuff like if i've got a three-quarters
of a pound of meat i'll just eat it and
i i just get it done and
you know i i i just do it but for other
folks that's where they could have say
like some ribs
and then if they don't have the shrimp
prepared like some frozen shrimp you
throw it in a pan
put some olive oil and a little bit of
seasoning on it then just put a lid on
it and it's going to kind of steam
it's not going to be the best shrimp you
ever had in your life but it's going to
be pretty damn good and it's hard to
screw it up you know and it required
two minutes of time you know just don't
burn it and it's going to be edible and
and pretty good and then i've got my my
two protein
combo there you know 30 grams of protein
from the steak 30 grams protein from the
shrimp
i'm i'm good to go what are the um
the insights around the amount of
protein you can absorb
per meal there's some rumors around it's
35 grams is this sort of a ceiling
within one sitting anything on top of
that just gets excreted out
have you looked into this yeah and it
you can absorb
a lot now you do start getting from an
anabolic
signaling perspective it does start kind
of plateau
diminishing out yeah you do get
diminishing returns on that but you do
also generally get really stable blood
glucose levels
you still have the new the fact that
protein dense protein sources are
nutritionally very dense so you're
getting all these vitamins and minerals
and
and whatnot that that comes along so i
think it's a little
myopic to just focus on like the
anabolic response of the protein
um this is where i think like the one
meal a day the omad stuff is really
problematic
you it's really difficult to get enough
anabolic signaling with one meal a day
like two meals two meals in a snack like
it makes it much
more reasonable to to uh support like
maintaining muscle mass and
and whatnot but yeah yeah got you how
about treats and sweet things
when you're trying to control sugar what
do you go to
i i have some uh dark chocolates and and
again like kind of catering to the kids
um we've found some dark chocolates that
they
like but they and and what i try to do
is find things that the whole family
can enjoy but they self-regulate i don't
want to be the food cop
at all you know and uh so we have some
keto ice creams that are called rebel
i'm not sure if you have this over in
the uk but
the best we've got sort of a like a low
carb ice cream but it's not going to be
the same ours would be a
like a halo top or something like that
it's going to be nothing nothing similar
to keto i don't think
this stuff is definitely better than a
halo top but i uh
it's um it's good
but what's interesting the the kids will
finish dinner they'll be running around
they're like hey can i have some rebel
i'm like absolutely so they they go pull
it out
and they scoop it up they self
self-regulate they self-serve
they have a bowl and they're done and
every once in a while like uh
there's a local uh ice creamery uh
pea sweet peas here here in montana
the rice cream is amazing it is not a
self-regulatable
deal you know like the kids will have a
much bigger bowl that they scoop
for themselves and then they finish the
bowl and then like 20 minutes later
they're like can i have some more of
that i'm like tomorrow you can have some
let's save some for tomorrow
so again i try not to super be the food
police guy but i
uh some keto ice cream some dark
chocolate
uh stuff like that i try to find things
that the kids
the kids really like chicharrones the
fried pork skins that are that are
flavored um definitely a kind of a
southern thing
but but uh my mom was from arkansas so
i've eaten so it's a salty crunchy
thing in instead of like a potato chip
kids love them but
it's also interesting they'll get a bowl
of them and they eat them
and then they go put the bowl on the
counter and they're done and so
that's the stuff that i i try to find
that the kids enjoy it but it's not that
cocaine-like deal where it's like i need
more
and so then they can start
self-regulating and we just have open
discussion with the kids we're like
yeah this other ice cream tastes really
good but like we would eat the whole
thing in one sitting right i'm like yeah
okay and this is all the work that mom
and dad do is trying to help people like
save their own lives from this amazing
tasting food and so we we just are
really honest and open with them about
that and we're like someday you're gonna
make your own decisions
and you can do what whatever you want to
do but a simple thing you can do is get
the ice cream that's
pretty good but not so good that you're
going to eat the whole thing in one
sitting and all right
okay that makes sense and so that's kind
of how we
we monitor that across the board like we
try to have a variety of of
options but stuff that uh all of us um
can self-regulate on like there are some
kind of
keto granolas and they're really good
like to the tune that my wife's like
hide this you know because she'll just
go back
and go back and go back and and so it it
it's funny even with some
stuff like that they put a little honey
glaze on it and you know they've got a
the mouth feel the crunch and everything
it's got some cinnamon like it's
really good in a big ass bag you could
crush the whole thing
easily just each time you walk by like
heck man like a quarter cup
you know super easy to do and each
quarter cup it's like 200 calories or
whatever you know so yeah
yeah that's awesome what about training
how does ancestral health get applied to
training i know that you were
the co-founder of the first ever and the
fourth ever
crossfit affiliate what what's the
paradigm
draw me on a spectrum from where
crossfit's at to sort of where you see
health and training and physical fitness
and stuff now oh man that's a really
good question
um i i think the most important thing is
whatever
folks are going to stick to like that
that stuff if your gig is walking your
gig is yoga and you just hate
everything else fine fine but
the one pitch that i would throw out to
people though is that as we
age there is we all have a potential
for cancer and for heart disease and for
neurodegenerative disease but we all
have a risk value of one we have a
hundred percent risk
of sarcopenia as we age
age-related muscle loss like we will
lose muscle
strength power volume as we age now we
can dramatically
change what happens with that based off
of some
some smart training and uh doing like a
full body
strength training session two times a
week can dramatically
um mitigate the the loss of muscle mass
as we age
and so even if you have somebody that
really hates strength training they
don't like being in the gym or whatever
um you join like one of these key in
24-hour fitness places it has a bunch of
machines
and you go and you you hit one machine
say like it's a bench press
and you you find a very light weight you
do it nice and easy for 15 reps
increase the weight do it for eight or
ten reps increase the weight to what for
five increase the weight grind out two
or three
and you're done now do a pull and then
you do your pull and now you do some
sort of a leg movement
maybe do a little bit of buys and tries
delts do some abs and low back and
you're done like you're in and out of
there in like 15 minutes doing this
uh kind of uh super set type format
you're never going to be a bodybuilder
you're never going to be a power lifter
doing that but like a
really like time efficient workout um
minimum investment maximum return i i
think stuff like that is incredible some
crossfit type stuff can be a little bit
like that too um
but i i just almost begged people to do
particularly out of that kind of like
yoga and endurance athlete scene it's
like running's great
cycling's great but uh let's do
something to fix your posture
let's do something to keep some muscle
mass in that upper body so when you
crash your bike hopefully your
your uh collarbone doesn't see you don't
get chuckled
exactly split into what about for
yourself then
obviously having had all of this time
and exposure to crossfit from
nearly 20 years now two decades of
exposure to that
where do you or how do you try and
optimize your training as someone who
obviously did enjoy the
high intensity the heavy weight the
loading etc
i i do everything physically now is kind
of geared towards just
doing brazilian jiu jitsu so i try to do
that two
two to four times a week uh it's usually
more like two
for the most part and then i do two days
a week of strength training
and it's a a press a pull a hinge a
lunge you know a squat something like
that
tends to be more like a five sets of
five
uh eight sets of three like kind of
heavier yeah
in between i do a lot of mobility work
from the kin stretch
frc world because i i noticed that
um you know because i sit a lot and
whatnot like uh
uh in the demands of jiu-jitsu that
mobility piece is another part like the
strength is really important but also
and mobility isn't just stretching like
it's actually figuring out how the joint
articulates and all that type of stuff i
remember i
i um i had to swerve to avoid hitting a
deer
and i hit kind of a curb and it knocked
my car out of alignment it took me like
two days to get to
the the tire place and the you know the
auto repair place
and the tire that was kind of just a
little cattywompus it was
destroyed like it and i didn't drive it
that much but
properly aligned tires like they wear
very very slowly and then you get it
just a tiny bit out of alignment
and it just shredded this thing it
stripped the
tires off and that's where like if
you're doing any type of repetitive
movement your shoulders your hips you
know your knees
and things aren't tracking well that's
where you end up really destroying the
joint surfaces so
some amount of mobility work i i think
is
really important so i mean my my main
focus is jiu jitsu
i do a couple of days a week of some
dedicated strength training
usually about one day sometimes two of
some low intensity cardio just kind of
recovery stuff
sometimes that's just wearing a weight
vest and taking the dog for a walk
sometimes it's putting on a
an episode of the expanse and getting on
my my air dyne and just kind of
kind of going at a nasal breathing pace
but that that's
most of what i do and one thing i
started doing in the
in the evenings instead of doing any tv
we listen to
some books on tape for the for the kids
and i just
do um stretching well that's going on i
get my phone
i set a timer i hold each position for
like four minutes
and and you know i do almost an hour of
stretching each night
but it's while we're hanging out as a as
a family it's crazy when you try and
socialize something like that
assistance recovery work some sort of
accessories
stretching if you're just chatting away
i went to um
crossfit reykjavik in iceland yeah a
couple of years ago have you ever been
mm-hmm yeah so i don't know when you
went because they
this thing grows extra limbs like like
an
um and when i was there the warm-up and
mobility warm-up and cool-down area
which is fully matted and looks like a
bjj
gym it's kind of recessed
right in the middle of a lateral gym and
from that viewing platform you can see
everything that's going on
so everybody arrives and rather than
standing by the reception desk
talking [ __ ] they sit on the mats and
talk [ __ ] but while they're sitting on
the mats they're doing stretching and
they're rolling their arms out and maybe
they've got a
massage going on themselves and then
everyone finishes and they go back there
and everyone's finished and they're
still doing the same and it was crazy
while i was out there training
you realize just how much more you get
done
and how much how much less painful it's
the same as
listening to an audiobook while you go
and do some
steady-state cardio or you've got a one
of your favorite tv shows on or
something while you're on a bike we had
a walk by
um throughout lockdown the my buddies
jim jordan very thankfully gave me a
watt bike which
i think saved me from probably about
five kilos of body weight gain
and um yeah i'd do podcast research i'd
be like right who've i got coming up
next
i've i've got rob wolf right i'll watch
rubble on the like hmvn
uh podcast or whatever it might be and i
just pop it on
and you think right it's a it's a
podcast at one and a half time speed and
before you know it you think
that's 45 minutes of cardio i've got in
i needed to watch this thing in any case
so yeah i'm a big big advocate of trying
to
um dampen down some of the inevitable
boredom that comes from the repetitive
less exciting stuff of exercise
by trying to pair it with something
that's a little bit more exciting and
interesting
absolutely yeah yeah and it frees up
the that uh it's very time efficient
like you're you're getting some
multitasking in but multitasking in a
way that doesn't make you crazy
it's not chaotic you know yeah that's a
really good way to put it
because you're already in this
presumably what you're not going to be
doing this while it's a cognitively
demanding task that while you're trying
to learn a new bjj move or something
like that you're not gonna be watching
something
so you're already probably somewhat
parasympathetic
you're already a little bit calm you may
be focusing on your breathing you said
moving it sort of a nasal breathing pace
when you're on the airdyne
and then you're watching this thing and
it's kind of kind of a nice experience
so you've
maybe got to either do a little bit of
research or watch your show or listen to
your audio book
but you don't have any of the guilt of
having just spent the last hour on
youtube or audible or whatever because
god i also got my training in yeah i
think um
i think that's a really good way to do
it talking about supplements
what is a supplement which people rely
on too much
in your opinion i think probably like a
multi-vitamin
like these high-dose multivitamins um
when you look at like the amounts and
the ratios of of b vitamins in
particular in these things they're
uh way way higher than what we would get
from any type of
food source and it's not dangerous
i think it could be i think it could be
like we're really these things are
really important in like methylation
pathways which are important in like uh
cancer regulation and whatnot and then
an interesting aside like the the
studies
looking at say like
vitamin supplementation use it really
doesn't it
there doesn't seem to be much upside
generally now i do think some folks end
up with some legitimate
deficiency scenarios and whatnot um
particularly if you're kind of more
vegan or vegetarian like b vitamins b12
in particular
really really important to supplement
but i'm kind of underwhelmed on that
like if somebody wanted to do
a a multivitamin
is just kind of hedging their bet i
would find one where they recommend like
six
tablets a day and you only take one and
maybe you take it every other day or
something like really just kind of a
a really baseline kind of hedging of
your bets but
trying to think about that like i i
think like just the general multivitamin
is probably one of those things that i i
think is
overused and and uh could lauren cordain
ages ago made made the case that um
these super high levels of b vitamins
could be problematic with different
types of
of cancers and it was really speculative
but i mean there's some mechanistic
stuff there that's kind of like i could
i could see where that could maybe be
problematic yeah what about a supplement
which is too underused
maybe vitamin d might i would say
actually creatine maybe because like it
seems like everybody should do creatine
like it seems like no
no downside it's neuroprotective it's an
antioxidant
even a non-athlete even even a
non-athlete yogurt
yeah yeah so maybe creatine but uh
man if uh if we could get everybody with
like a sporty vitamin d lamp
i i think that that would solve so many
so many problems like uh
you know just uh if we had community
vitamin d lamps where you could just
like
go walking you know strip down zipper
something close do
three minutes front three minutes back
and and then go about your day like i i
think that that could be amazing for
seasonal affective disorder all these
other things that we know are definitely
vitamin d
driven um but
the bugger there is it like
supplementing say like liquid vitamin d
um it doesn't seem to do quite the same
thing to getting it from the sun does
but
it definitely seems to confer a benefit
so that's where like
if we could rig up some sort of a smart
uv
supplementation process to generate that
vitamin d would be pretty cool
how much better is the smart uv versus
oral supplement i don't know
but it just um there are some folks uh
pedro bastos he's he's
in uh lisbon portugal he's really smart
on this stuff as are some other
uh physicians that are kind of kind of
uh tight with him
um they
they understand the research on this
much better than i do but
you know kind of the limitations about
how they are looking at vitamin d
oftentimes also these vitamin d studies
there's supplementing with really paltry
amounts it's like 400 ius a day and you
should be doing
like 5 000 ius a day to really start
moving the
the needle at all so there's a lot of
there's a lot of challenges within
interpreting what's going on there the
stuff that we can hang our hat on
is that it seems like when folks have
adequate vitamin d levels particularly
from from sunlight like there's all this
other stuff that happens like it
releases nitric oxide it's immune
modulating
um kind of baited endorphin activation
so you just kind of cognitively feel
better um
we have more that we can hang our hat on
with that and then the supplementation
side is just harder to kind of ferret
out like
what what exactly is going on here yeah
um what are your thoughts on nicotine um
i'm seeing more talk now about people
reducing their caffeine intake
and then using a nicotine gum or
something else
as a shorter acting stimulant i
i like it in a what is that what are you
holding
these are mints and i like the mints
because the gum i i start getting like
tmj from
chewing it too much but um uh
this first got on my radar when i was
doing work for naval special warfare
uh resiliency program back in 2008-2009
and it what they wanted me to talk about
was uh
sleep food uh booze
caffeine and nicotine to uh different
navy seal groups which was
was really cool and and super
interesting and in trying to do my
diligence
i i wanted to look at the toxicology of
nicotine
and when i really started digging in and
looking at it was really interesting it
was like
man the problem with this is the
delivery system like tobacco is really
really bad for you
it's terrible carcinogen whether you're
chewing it or or
smoking it but just nicotine as a
standalone item
can't quite call it a vitamin but it
does some really interesting stuff
and one interesting thing is when you
look at neurodegenerative disease
among smokers it's shockingly low
and this is kind of mind-blowing because
neuro did
the brain is so
exposed to like oxidative stress to
microvascular stress like
it you know it is so a kind of
exposed in that regard but yet whatever
it is that nicotine is doing which it
seems to be modifying like the the
dopamine release and then clearly the
nicotinic receptor sites it's
so beneficial that it like i i forget
the exact numbers but i want to say that
among smokers the the uh incidence
of parkinson's and alzheimer's is like
40 percent less 60 percent less like
it's stunningly less this is one of
these things that medicine is just kind
of like
nobody talk about this [ __ ] you know it
it because it is
it's too confusing but then what it's
fascinating
when you keep digging and digging it
you find some articles that are like how
do we get our patients who have
successfully quit smoking off of
nicotine gum
and there's all this like back and forth
and hand wringing
and then you you get to like this final
page there's a webmd
article that's like three pages long
it's remarkably long and then it finally
wraps it up and it's like maybe this
isn't that big of a deal it's almost
like the person started the process like
i did
and they kept working their way through
and then they get to the spot and
they're like
at the end of the day there's none of
the health detrimental health effects
that we see
with uh nicotine gum and and mints
relative to tobacco ingestion so maybe
it's not that big of a
a deal but it i i i can ping you that
that article is really
it's kind of interesting it's like it
was a a
journal a journal or a train of
consciousness thing that they just
wrote because they clearly had kind of
one orientation at the beginning and
then this thing
webmd articles are not typically like
four pages long and this thing kept
going and going and
so yeah i'm a i'm a big fan
i just use it for uh kind of focus and
and interestingly also
um although my gut health issues have
improved a ton
over time it just seems to improve my
my digestion and my gut health and this
is another
interesting thing when you when you look
at like ulcerative colitis
crohn's um those things tend to improve
if people begin smoking and tend to
worsen if they stop smoking
and so it is just another one of those
definitely the digestive part and then
also
kind of the neurocognitive part yeah so
you use it as a nootropic
what's dosage and i take a four
milligram mint and i bite it in half so
it's two milligrams and then i just
stick it
between my my lip and just let it dry
is it sublingual this one is yeah
yeah yeah um something that you might be
interested in scott alexander
from slate star codex do you feel me
familiar with this
okay so he's now on um uh
what's he on sub stack as astral codex
10.
he just released within the last 200
or 20 uh uh no tropics
yes have you seen it did you watch it i
i have not watched it yet i
watched it read it i listened to it on
the podcast that an australian dude does
of it um which was actually totally
awful to listen to because he's just
describing what's in a bar
chart um so that that was a really awful
one to listen to but i was listening to
it earlier on today
it was like torture um but yeah they go
through dude they go through
all sorts there's probably 50 plus
compounds in there
um he gets rid of a few that have got
such a small
number of suggestions that it kind of
wouldn't make sense to put it in there
but it's there's people talking about
microdosing lsd where that ranks
microdosing psilocybin fenney but
like uh nmd nad
everything and um that's that was
fascinating i'm gonna
it's saved to my pocket to watch later
so yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna have a little look at that i
thought that was really really
interesting when i look
uh next to the screen that you are in i
have a tab open
with that astral codex uh topic right
right
no way ready to roll yeah yeah yeah how
funny that guy is brilliant
that guy is brilliant he's he's
operating on a
whole different level like dude yeah
i don't know if i would love hanging out
with that guy or i would want to like
throttle him he's so smart like i i it
would be either or i don't think it
would be any middle ground
the thing that i think is most
terrifying about scott
is his ability to write clearly yeah
he has the least
barriers that the fewest restrictions
from brain to fingertip
of of potentially anyone that i know
so you had um who did doors of
perception aldous huxley
right so you what you did what we did in
the 60s and 70s was
we needed somebody with the linguistic
capability to describe this incredibly
complex
experience so what happens we find like
the writer
of the era right and we call him in like
the champion to come slay the dragon and
we say right okay you're going to
experience this thing
that basically few people struggle to
put into words
try your best tell us what you see and
what scots does
for free every single day for 15 years
is try and wrangle the chaos of the
entire world and all of his inner
sort of vacillations as well
um and he puts them dude he did one have
you read one called
untitled it was about feminism yeah
yeah man that is
it's a a magnum opus of someone being
able to
go from to just see
clearly he sees what's going on and then
he's able to
repurpose it into words the man is he's
phenomenal i love him
yeah i'm terrified of him at the same
time i he only got on my radar maybe
about
nine months ago somebody forward a piece
that he did
um the only thing i can't tolerate is
intolerance
and it was so i thought it was
completely in response to like the
current
cancel culture scene it was written in
like 2008
and i i was just like oh my god like
this is
amazing you know and and so prescient
like really really incredible and then i
was
oh i just went so far down that rabbit
hole like who is this guy
you know yeah endless it's one of those
people it's it's the fortune i'm sure
that you have it with your show as well
and
and now this will be episode 320
something
um it's great because when you find a
new creator that you really
like and then you realize that they have
this sort of
alexandra's library of past
content and you think god i can i i
don't need to listen to anyone else or
read anyone else for the rest of my life
i can just go through
i can just go through this um a couple
of a couple of other blog posts of his
that i absolutely adored so meditations
on molok
um is the single best thing i've ever
read
um so it's about 25 000 30 000 words so
it's a
couple of hour read but it's outstanding
it's it's absolutely amazing it's very
profoundly sort of changed the way that
i see the world
and then he did another one about um is
it the only thing i can't bear
is the out group and it's talking about
in group out group differences
and that's really interesting because i
had um i had a sociologist on recently
and he was talking about the fact that
before 2012
both democrats or specifically democrats
they preferred
their own party members of their own
party to their hatred of the other party
but in 2012 the reason that democrats
voted democrat wasn't that they loved of
the other democrats
it was that they hated the opposite side
more so their hatred was a motivation
greater than their like
and that simply understanding that which
is explained in in group versus out
group by scott
explains so much of what's going on
yeah yeah and it paints a really
um dangerous and kind of depressing
picture because it's going to be very
difficult to unfuck and walk all that
back
like it it's it's it's bad news like it
is
really really bad news yeah yeah
rob mann thank you so much for today
it's been a while coming i'm very very
glad we managed to finally get it done
a huge honor being here really enjoyed
the time and thank you for uh
putting up with the multiple schedule
tweaks we had to do
do not mention it so uh drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom i was chatting to blake
earlier on so we've got something set up
for the listeners for that
um where else should people go they want
to find out about this the health
revolution stuff
the healthy rebellion is
join.thehealthyrebellion.com and they
can check out the
the podcast uh same title healthy
rebellion radio
and you kind of get a sense of a lot of
what we're up to we kind of describe
what goes on in the healthy rebellion
and also we just do a lot of q a uh my
wife and i do that
yeah and that's most of where i'm at i'm
not on i have stuff that looks like me
on social media but it's
it's mainly me writing stuff and my
assistant posting it you won't get a
response on social media from me that's
for sure
well if it's helping you sleep i think
it's worthwhile rob brother thank you so
much for coming on thank you
take care thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips
from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
it makes me very happy indeed peace